this morning we are taking another look
at a victim of russia's disinformation
war in ukraine last week you'll recall
we showed you chris livesay's report
inside a bio research lab in ukraine
that was falsely accused of creating
biological weapons it's a phony charge
and it's spread on social media some
americans even some american lawmakers
believe it now in the second part of his
exclusive story chris spoke to two
scientists who find themselves targets
of those same russian lies and we have
chris on set chris good morning yes good
morning a russian conspiracy theory has
proven to be a deadly weapon without any
evidence the kremlin says the u.s has
been helping ukraine develop biological
weapons and caught in the cross hairs
in the kremlin's crosshairs is an
american woman and her canadian husband
in the capital kiev
black tea in a blacked out kitchen
anything to protect yulana and marco
suprune from russian shelling in their
kiev home you're gonna die for something
anyway might as well you know do it
standing up i think everyone the target
on their heads is bigger than most a
doctor born in detroit to ukrainian
parents yulano was once ukraine's health
minister credited with modernizing the
former soviet republic's laboratories to
prevent a deadly outbreak according to
russian disinformation she hatched an
evil plot to cause one instead that i
was a cia agent that came here
specifically to design bio labs to
create biological weapons and to
experiment on ukrainians a conspiracy
theory and a deadly weapon
putin claims it's one reason he invaded
ukraine because of military labs right
on his border cbs news was granted
exclusive access to one lab in his
crosshairs built to detect and diagnose
some of the world's most infectious
diseases
cholera anthrax everything
not to make weapons says chief of
research natalia vedaco but to test for
diseases in patients and all of them she
says were destroyed in labs across the
country once russia invaded precisely to
prevent a possible outbreak
so you put the pathogens in here yes
this special program
and it destroys them yes it makes them
so that they can't hurt anything
but that hasn't stopped moscow's attacks
on ulana and marco with online posts
accusing them of having nazi links
so
my initial reaction was um
holy crap like they're
they're coming after us
not only on social media at defense
briefings too
the pentagon warns russian forces could
be laying the ground for a false flag
attack using biological weapons of their
own but blaming it on ukraine the
disinformation is causing people to die
it's not just
disinformation it actually has real life
consequences you're aware of of the fear
right you hold uh hugs a little longer
you um
you don't want to lose each other yeah
but that's a price they say they're
willing to pay
like so many victims in this war of
information
and like alana supreme said
disinformation can be deadly the kremlin
now asserts it's just found american
training materials in the ukrainian lab
on how to weaponize smallpox a baseless
claim that russia says justifies this
bloody invasion well yolanna knew what
her husband was trying to say it must be
very frightening to have to live that
way when you know that the information
is false that it could cost you your
life yeah yeah and it could i mean you
could be a target not just you but your
country i mean this is a this is
something that russia is using to
justify this invasion that's killed tens
of thousands of people now they said if
you're going to die you might as well do
a standing up yeah about that chris good
to have you at the table very soon